If you really want to hear about just the
worst of the worst of the left, you have to
hear about what's happening over the last
72 hours.
Now, last week, I got a phone call during
live calls on last Friday show from a viewer
asking me, what do I think about the AOC versus
Jimmy Dorje debate?
And when the caller asked me about it, I had
no idea what it was about.
And the caller explained to me very, very
politely, the debate is that a YouTube named
Jimmy Dorje thinks that the squad should hold
their votes for Nancy Pelosi's speaker of
speakership hostage unless Nancy Pelosi is
willing to hold a vote in the House for Medicare
for all.
And when the caller brought it up, I hadn't
heard about it at the time.
It started on Twitter the previous weekend.
I don't watch the show that the caller mentioned.
I wasn't on Twitter over the over that weekend,
so I had no idea.
I have now learned about it thanks to the
caller.
And the same thing continued to explode this
weekend.
We're now even AOC apparently isn't progressive
enough.
AOC is failing progressive purity tests because
she's unsure about the value of holding her
vote hostage for a Medicare for all vote in
the House.
She's questioning whether that would really
do anything for people with acute needs right
now.
Now, the funny thing about all of this is
that there's a bunch of funny things and some
sad things and so infuriating things.
One of the funny things about this is that
for the last several years, when it comes
to AOC, I've mostly been attacked for being
too critical of AOC and for not being deferential
enough to any of these notions.
When I found that she lacked knowledge or
pragmatism in one place or another, I would
mention that people would be furious with
me.
Now, AOC is actually the one being pragmatic
and the so-called populist left has turned
on her.
And what's really bonkers is that the populist
left seems more angry with AOC than they are
with Donald Trump.
When Trump is going lunatic, authoritarian
and had an Oval Office meeting over the weekend
about whether he should declare martial law
if he even could, whether he should seize
voting machines by force because he lost an
election and he can't admit it.
But the populist left on Twitter is focused
on AOK now.
In fact, I actually said about seven to eight
months after AOK was sworn in.
You know, guys, I have to tell you, I am pleased
that Aoki's political instincts are maturing.
Since she's gotten into Congress, her political
instincts improved dramatically from the campaign
AOC to when she was actually in office.
Her pragmatism and her understanding of how
politics works improved dramatically.
And now, if you said to me right now, what
is the most important thing to keep in mind
about this issue?
What is the most instructive, possible takeaway
about this spat that is taking place within
the left, mostly on Twitter and Reddit?
Well, there's actually a few takeaways.
Number one, there is nothing wrong with.
I want people to take out a notepad and make
a note of what I'm about to say and don't
email me about it, OK, because I'm telling
you right now there's nothing wrong with people
on the left criticizing others on the left.
Nothing wrong with that.
There's nothing wrong with progressives, primarily
centrist or corporate Democrats.
That should be.
That's great.
That should be encouraged.
OK, great.
There's nothing wrong with any of those things
at a structural level.
But the takeaways here are, number one, the
so-called populist left on Twitter.
And Reddit represents a small but very vocal
Internet enclave that does not connect to
most of what's happening in the real world.
Now, we learned this sadly.
It was a rude awakening during the Democratic
primary.
How could Bernie possibly have lost?
He had so much energy.
He had the best streams.
He had the best rallies.
If you spent time on Twitter and Reddit, it
looked like Bernie couldn't possibly have
lost that primary.
But he lost the primary by millions of votes
because most of the electorate and the Democratic
Party voters are not in the Internet populist
left space.
It's not a value judgment.
It's an evaluation of fact.
And if we don't get it, it'll continue to
go this way.
And this is the exact same thing.
If you're a factory worker, dad, who's trying
to figure out how to put food on your family's
table for your two kids while continuing to
work during a pandemic, and your employer
might have to lay off 10 percent of the workforce
due to the pandemic and you might be in that
10 percent laid off.
Do you need a list of the members of Congress
who support Medicare for all right now, particularly
absent any actual credible way to get it passed
as we are about to get a new Congress seated?
I'm not saying the dad doesn't care about
Medicare.
Get Medicare for all.
I'm not saying that dad wouldn't benefit from
Medicare.
For all I'm saying.
Does anyone outside of these online spaces
think that what is effectively a naughty and
nice list in a Congress that has two weeks
left before some some leave and some new people
get sworn in, that's what that dad cares about.
Or imagine a business owner in Houston who
sells wedding dresses, OK, and has seen their
business decimated due to this due to the
pandemic.
They're waiting on a second stimulus.
They're wondering when will people go back
to weddings?
That business owner is waiting on a vote on
Medicare for all, which there is not even
support for in the Senate anyway, and which
Joe Biden didn't run on what just to have
a list of people to primary.
So the point isn't that there's no place for
such a vote or that it shouldn't be done.
I'm fine with it.
But attacking AOC now, because she's far more
realistic about how politics works than much
of the populist left, when we're we're trying
to get a second stimulus, it looks like we're
going to get a pathetic one.
And we have so many other issues going on.
And again, the president is talking about
martial law and seizing voting machines.
The point is, AOC now is not left enough.
She's not passed the progressive purity test.
It's another example of the left eating itself.
If these people are even on the left, I'm
not sure.
And that's what's tricky about populist rhetoric.
It sounds very similar on the left and right
until you get to the solutions.
Some of the so-called populist left now attacking
AOC is praising Tulsi Gabbard, whose recent
ideas on trans people and abortion don't look
like anything I recognize as being part of
the left.
So maybe the issue and I'm thinking out loud
here, maybe the issue is that some of these
people aren't really leftists.
They seem more into what Tucker Carlson is
proposing than what we see from AOC.
Now, again, there are people who say, I'm
not really on the left.
So starting to to say, well, this person is
not really what they claim to be.
I get that it's fraught and that it's problematic.
And my point, again, just to restate it, is
not that the left shouldn't criticize the
left when the left fails to be left, as I've
done many times.
But the real issue here is that it seems to
be a complete loss of the plot for lack of
a better term.
Trump considering martial law and people are
saying AOC being unwilling to do something
that will make no political difference anyway
makes her enemy number one.
This is how the left keeps losing.
I want the left to win.
I don't think this is the path to victory.
Let me know what you think.
I would love to hear from you.
Remember that on January 1st, we will be doing
a one day membership special.
The idea is to set the one day record for
new memberships.
As we've speculated, my immoral, illegal membership
specials could be clamped down on by the incoming
Biden administration.
So you got to get those memberships before
Biden is sworn in.
That's that's a joke.
Everybody, relax.
We're just kidding around.
But in all seriousness, on January 1st, we'll
send out an email blast with a monstrous membership
special if you want to be notified of.
It just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com and let me know what you think about
this entire AOK thing, you can find me on
Twitter at David Pakman, The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.